it's september 2nd so it's time for
another monthly update video i'm going
to talk about what went on in august
what we've got coming up in september
and i always like to begin by
highlighting three big things that you
might want to take note of so big thing
number one
tomorrow we're going to have a big
announcement about stoicon 2022 if
you're not familiar with stoicon it is
like the largest
gathering of people interested in
stoicism it's online it's worldwide
and there's a lot of great speakers and
things lined up for it so you'll find
out about that
fairly shortly
second big thing i was asked very very
last minute if i would teach some
classes for marquette university as it
turns out i'm teaching three classes for
them which quadrupled my teaching load
for the fall
third big thing comes out of that second
big thing so two of the classes are
oriented around this capstone core class
that's now required for students there
and i am teaching two sections of that
it's supposed to be centered around a
particular big problem and so i chose
the big problem
of anger and so we're spending uh an
entire semester looking at not only
martha nussbaum's book on anger that's
fairly recent but all sorts of classical
and contemporary discussions about anger
what it is its relationship to justice
and injustice and so you can expect a
lot of really cool content on that
coming out some of which i have released
already so those are the three big
things um
let's talk about the month of august
so august started out pretty good but it
started to get busier and busier as i
got asked with less than a month before
classes started if i would take on the
up to three classes for marquette
university and i agreed to do that so
there's been a lot of you know sort of
rescheduling and retooling because
designing building
and getting classes ready takes an awful
lot of work it was also the month of my
52nd birthday
and i'm glad that quite a few people
were able to participate in my online
birthday bash my
wife and i also you know had a nice
dinner and then that weekend went down
to chicago and saw duran duran
a band that i've loved since i was a kid
so that was an awful lot of fun i also
ended up
for about the last
week and a half of the month wound up
with an infection
and that really took me out took the
wind out of my sails so to speak when it
comes to energy so it's kind of a
perfect storm of more work
less energy i didn't get quite as many
things done as i was hoping but i did
get one
event uh the philosophers in the midst
of history
discussion that um i i did with the
frank weinberg library on
hegel
well attended we had some great
discussions and a lot of fun
with that
i also shot quite a few videos you may
have seen some of the sadler's stories
or the evil saddler that came out
recently or the
uh hegel asides rants digressions i did
a caption contest i actually did two
twitter
conversations where i saw something
interesting happening on twitter and
then did some you know screenshots of
the conversations i also finished up
teaching my light hall class on
aristotle and the moral virtues and i
gave you some samplers of what went in
what went on in those classes people
liked those quite a bit
and i i shot a lot of core concept
videos on um arthur schopenhauer's on
the basis of morality part three which i
had been wanting to do for quite some
time
and also on for the new class on
aristotle's rhetoric book two
uh definition and discussion of anger
and its opposite
calmness and i finished remastering the
epictetus and caridian
videos and releasing those
on the saddlers lectures podcast
um i started the month doing a lot of
stuff on alchemin of york a great
medieval thinker uh who
has a wonderful treatise called on
virtues and vices then we went into
heidegger's uh plato's doctrine of truth
five uh podcast episodes on that and
then uh aristotle nick mccann ethics
book six where he's talking about the
intellectual virtues and i have been
releasing those so that is what has been
going on
in the month of august and uh let's talk
now about what's coming up
september is going to be quite a busy
month for us here not only do i have um
four academic classes that i am teaching
and designing trying to get back to the
gym as well we're doing a little bit of
travel uh for for you know music events
and things like that so i'm not doing
quite as many
of the
usual events that i would be doing but
things are kicking off tomorrow with
our monthly ama that's ask me anything
session so if you've got questions for
me pop in and go ahead and ask them that
is at noon central time i should preface
too and say that all these events are
going to be central time so if you're
not in the central time zone you do want
to check what the time zone difference
is going to be
also tomorrow on the 3rd at 2 p.m i'll
have philosophy chat for patreon
supporters
um on the 10th at noon and at 1 30.
we're gonna have the two different parts
of worlds of speculative fiction i
didn't quite get to uh releasing the
stuff on jg ballard
and uh his his trio of crash uh concrete
island and high rise that i've been
shooting video footage on that starts at
noon with a video premiere and then we
have at 1 30 some ongoing discussion
in zoom for people who want to
talk more about the books and the author
on the 14th at 5 p.m we'll have our
hegel q a and discussion session that's
open to the public you don't have to be
a patreon supporter for that but it is
underwritten by patreon supporters and
then a week later
uh on the 21st at
uh 3 p.m we will have the patreon
exclusive hegel q a and discussion and
then we'll finish up the month
on the 29th at 6 00 pm with the
milwaukee stoic fellowship which is held
online you don't have to be a member or
live in milwaukee to participate in it
we'll be talking mostly about the season
of stoicism coming up stoicon stoic week
all the cool events that are going to be
happening um i do want to get back to
shooting uh half our hegel videos this
month i didn't succeed in doing any this
last month but i'm hoping to do those
and
catch up on book reviews as well i'm a
bit backlogged on that i'll probably
shoot some personal videos
maybe do another caption contest and
then a lot of core concept videos i've
got more coming out on aristotle i'm
shooting some stuff on audrey lorde's
the use of anger which is what i started
my my uh classes with
um
doing that this weekend and i'll
probably release those next week
uh and then joseph butler some of his
sermons that have to do with anger and
resentment and forgiveness um
maybe i'll get to loch tonsius and you
know his treaties on the anger of god or
on divine anger
and if i'm really really ambitious i'll
get some lucretius things shot having to
do with the the nature of the will
for my foundations of philosophy class
i'm also going to be working on podcast
stuff and releasing those got more
aristotle nick mccann ethics book 6
episodes to release and then i'm going
to be doing some on descartes discourse
on method which i did videos on a long
time ago and i'm teaching a class on it
and i i need those podcast episodes for
that and then if we have time i'll shoot
some more
videos or rather create some more
podcast episodes from videos on
epictetus's discourses but we'll see how
far i get with that that might be overly
ambitious given the heavy
workload that i have you know i still
have a lot of
client based work i'm giving a lot of
talks coming up this term getting ready
for stoic con
uh still editing stoicism today volume
four and of course you know creating all
of this content so i hope that you can
uh you know participate in some of these
online
events that we've got coming up and that
you enjoy the video content the podcast
content and might even get to a little
bit of writing this month if
things pan out well so i'll see you and
i hope that you have a great month ahead
you